my hair looks so clean I'd really just
took a shower and I guess that's
actually what the purpose of a shower
yes I still think it's mostly just the
ring light in that the actual shower
no I'm man yourself do not no no you
know your life is different now this
videos different so I wanted to make
something I don't know what well I kind
of know what this is but now I've over
analysed it too much so this might be
over processed but I'm just gonna word
bomb it to you for a little bit a couple
of you would tweeted at me asking if I
was going to do a Coachella fashion
review and because fashion views have
become one of the main staples of my
channel as of the last like year or so I
thought I should do that and so then I
tweeted asking for looks that you wanted
me to review and I shot the whole video
yesterday and then I it's 7:15 p.m.
today and I've had all day to edit this
video and I just didn't want to because
I didn't like it while I was shooting
the video I didn't like it Coachella
Coachella is
well I was sleeping last night thinking
about having to edit the video today I
didn't like it I just got such an icky
sensation in my body about making this
video and then I realized maybe it's
because I went to therapy earlier today
who knows I'm gonna double down and say
it's the ring light that helped me come
to this epiphany I just didn't want to
make this video and I didn't want to
force making this video because it feels
like something I should do rather than
something I want to do and that's where
we are on that I ran on the treadmill
after I got back from therapy because I
helps me process my thoughts a lot more
and I had such a succinct articulate
minded brain about the message that I
wanted to sit down and do for you guys
but then I got self-conscious about
wanting to look cute in the video so I
took a shower I dried my hair I did my
hair I did my makeup and that succinct
seed of beautiful what I thought thought
has grown into this like kind of
sparsely watered shrub forgive me for
not being so succinct who knows if
there's an actual message I think it's
just me being frank with you guys that
was the original title of being John
Malkovich being Frank know the Sun is
setting so it's just gonna get more
dramatic and it's gonna look like I'm
doing either an apology video or a
coming out video or a crisis video and
it's none of the above it's just like
this is what I think right now I want to
kind of turn this into a stream of
consciousness video I feel like that's a
much more positive and optimistic way
describing the fact that you are going
through a little bit but just bit not
even a lot just a bit a little epiphany
little Epiphany oh well that's a great
rap name you can have that aspiring
suburban rapper that might be watching
this video I would genuinely enjoyed
making fashion review videos not as of
late and so rather than forcing a round
peg into a fashion review hall I decided
that I would respectfully respect myself
and not post that instead I'm posting
this you guys have probably picked up on
this if you've been watching these
videos for awhile but it's kind of
process I'm going through right now is
figuring out like what what do I want to
do what
that question a lot like my normal
carry-on luggage has weights and
everything about it is necessary and
it's extremely hard to unpack I'm a very
impatient person so the idea of being in
like a flux State creatively or in a
Burnout state or a weird in-between
pivoting kind of this moment is
unbearable sometimes and it's paralyzing
you don't want to make anything you
don't know how to trust your instincts
because they're just kind of figuring
out new ways to figure things out I
think I like was self triggered by the
idea of making a fashion review video
just because it felt like I was holding
on and grasping at this like old version
of myself and wishing that like 2011
grace like still existed in the internet
world and turns out it doesn't and it's
gonna believe me to hold on to those
hoops I've been watching a lot of TV and
that's how you know that your creative
brain is scared is when you just sort of
like hermit down and this is coming from
a naturally born hermit which i think is
okay in a lot of cases but when you
fully like triple down on your hermitage
and just seek out reality TV programming
as a distraction rather than an
inspiration you know that you gotta make
some changes so that's kind of where I'm
at right now I've talked about this
before but I talk about a lot on my
podcast not too deep and I think the
most recent episode that I did with
Chelsea Handler that went up on Monday
really inspired me because she's gone
through this new sort of like another
adult puberty where she's discovering
all the reasons that she has acted the
way she is in the way she wants to be
and is actually making active changes
and that was just like for someone that
really has idolized her and been
inspired by her and her journey
professionally to see like her personal
journey come to light as someone that is
norm
only pretty private about that stuff I
just loved that it almost like gave me
permission to feel okay making a video
like this that is just cuz if my throat
doesn't want me to be genuine with you
guys it's as if my body is still
resisting the idea of letting down
another small curtain and allowing you
to see a little bit more into my windows
because all of my neighbors have fully
seen me fully naked in my house
physically not emotionally it energizes
me to be honest and frank with my Frank
Frank get out of here Frank it energizes
me to be totally Tony with myself let's
be real that right now my creative brand
isn't working the way I would love it to
but maybe it's because it's supposed to
work differently in the future and I
need to give it some time in some space
and fuel it in a creative way that
allows me to figure out what the next
evolution of whatever this nonsense is
this is a woowoo kind of concept that is
common sense but I just wanted to let
you guys know as someone that hates
letting people down which is another
thing I'm talking about in therapy that
I appreciate the enthusiasm about the
potential of a Coachella fashion review
but I just don't give a [ __ ] also
everyone dressed exactly the same they
were a variation of straps and fringe
and thongs as much as we want to say
that Coachella is the Outback Steakhouse
of music festivals where there's no
rules it's just right everyone kind of
abides by the same sort of fashion rules
every year this is for sure very
rambling and might not make any sense to
you but if there's anything to take away
from this and this is me talking to me
now and so now you're being like a creep
listening to me talking to me give
yourself permission to say no to
something that makes you feel bad don't
judge yourself for not wanting to do
something that you think you should do
and then see what happens from there
your brains like a car give it some good
fuel take it out to the highway and see
where the wind up sounds a good Bon Jovi
song so that's that and I really hope
that you listen to or watch the episode
of not too deep with Chelsea Handler
that just went up because that was very
inspiring for me and I like I said has
helped me start kind of reanalyzing and
reconnecting with what I'm doing and why
I'm doing it
I'm feeling doing it I hope you guys are
having a great time do whatever you're
doing don't hurt anyone for yourselves
I don't know why I'm creating a new sign
off that isn't necessary other than that
I don't know
did I say everything I wanted to say
probably absolutely definitely not I
also don't know exactly what I'm trying
to say read between the lines you know
the lines are all the flips over the
place I'm gonna toot my own horn but
like oh gosh
when did my hair it look like a Pantene
pro-v commercial